.
>> Jesse: AMERICA HEARS YOU.
A MASSIVE RUSSIAN MILITARY
CONVOY MAKING ITS WAY TO KYIV
JUST MILES AWAY FROM THE
CAPITAL.
BILL HEMMER JOINS US NOW FROM
THE BIG BOARD WITH THE LATEST ON
RUSSIA'S OMINOUS PUSH, BILL?
>> Bill: AMAZING INTERVIEW.
THAT TOWN OF CAR CHIEF WHICH SHE
IS COMING FROM GOT 1.4 MILLION
PEOPLE JESSE, LIKE THE SIZE OF
SAN DIEGO.
SAN DIEGO, CALIFORNIA HAS
1.4 MILLION PEOPLE.
PHOENIX, ARIZONA IS 1.6 MILLION.
THAT GIVES YOU A SENSE OF THE
RELATIVE SIZE OF KHARKIV IN THE
NORTHEAST.
THIS TOWN HAS BEEN POUNDED OVER
THE LAST TWO DAYS.
JESSE YOU WERE JUST SHOWING
VIDEO THERE A MOMENT AGO
RESIDENTIAL AREAS.
JUST ABOUT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE BUILDINGS HAS SOME SORT OF
SHOT REAL WILL HE REMARKABLE
STUFF.
ALL THIS CLEARS PUT AT RISK.
JUST WATCHED THAT STORY.
WHAT I DID FOR YOU JESSE HERE
GOES BACK TO LAST THURSDAY.
FEBRUARY 24TH.
CAR KYIV, DOWN HERE PUT THE MAP
IN MOTION DAY BY DAY.
JESSE, IT'S NOT SIGNATURE CASTS.
IT JUST VERY SAULTZ.
EVERYTHING YOU SEE IN RED.
THIS IS FRIDAY.
I KNOW IT'S SUGGESTION, BUT IT'S
SIGNIFICANT WHEN YOU ARE TRYING
TO ADVANCE IN WAR LIKE THIS.
AND THAT 27 OF FEBRUARY.
AGAIN, THE NORTH, THE NORTHEAST,
AND THE SOUTH HERE.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE IT
ADVANCES ONE MORE TIME HERE.
SO THIS IS KHARKIV THE TOWN I
DESCRIBED.
20 MILES ON THE NEAR SIDE OF
RUSSIA.
JESSE WE SAW SATELLITE IMAGES
TAKEN ON THURSDAY.
SHOW ENORMOUS MILITARY STAGING
AREA.
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY HAS THE
CAPACITY TO GO BACK AND FORTH
OVER THE BORDER AND RESUPPLY IF
IT WANTS TO HIT THIS TOWN EVEN
MORE.
TO THE NORTH CAPITAL CITY OF
KYIV RIGHT HERE.
IF I CAN GET THIS THING GOING
HERE.
THIS THE BORDER.
BELARUS RIGHT THERE TURNS INTO
RUSSIA AT DAY BREAK EARLIER
TODAY ONE OF OUR BIG STORIES ON
"AMERICA'S NEWSROOM" WHERE THE
PEACE TALKS, I SHOULD CALL THEM
TRUIST TALKS THAT WERE UNDERWAY
IN BELARUS WHAT CAME OF THEM,
IT'S A LITTLE UNCERTAIN BUT THEY
DID AGREE TO TALK AGAIN NEAR THE
BELARUS POLISH BORDER.
HERE IS THE CAPITAL CITY DOWN
HERE ABOUT.
160 MILES, JESSE, FROM THE
BORDER HERE IS ABOUT 90 MILES.
THIS IS REALLY, I MEAN, THAT'S
BEEN THE PUSH FROM THE NORTH.
FOR THE RUSSIAN ARMY TO GET ON
THESE ROADS.
STUNNING, LINED UP TWO ACROSS
FOR MILES.
SOMETIMES THREE ACROSS FOR MILES
WONDER AT WHAT POINT THEY ARE
ABLE TO BREACH THIS CITY HOW
MUCH POWER THE RUSSIAN ARMY
TAKES WITH THIS INTO THE CAPITAL
CITY OF KYIV.
TAKE YOU DOWN HERE JUST IN
CRIMEA AND THE SOUTH, THIS WAS
REALLY AN UNCONTESTED BATTLE
HERE.
THERE IS AN IRRIGATION CANAL
THAT SEPARATES CRIMEA FROM THE
REST OF UKRAINE.
ONCE THAT CANAL IS BREACHED BY
TANKS.
PRETTY MUCH ON BEHALF OF
UKRAINIAN ARMY.
AND ANY OF THE REPORTING WE ARE
GETTING HERE SUGGESTS THAT'S THE
CASE OF THE RUSSIAN ARMY IS
RIGHT ACROSS THE CRIMEA AND
UKRAINE AND DO WHAT IT WANTED.
AND GO IN ANY DIRECTION IT
WANTS.
AND SO I WOULD JUST SAY, JESSE,
IN THE DAYS TO COME, MARY POLL
IS A MARIUPOL.
PORT CITY POPULATION ABOUT
450,000.
AND THEN IF YOU -- IF PUTIN
WANTS, HE COULD EVENTUALLY TRY
AND CONNECT THE DONBAS REGION,
WHICH IS WHERE WE WERE BACK IN
2014 OVER TO CHER SHAN INTO
ODESA.
WATCH THAT STORY TO COME THAT
BRIDGE PUT INTO PLACE TACTICAL
MANEUVER HARD